hallo meine Lieben wir machen heute
Stollen und das ist das erste
Stollenrezept auf meinem Kanal
tatsächlich aber ich habe so ein kleines
Kiki Upgrade daraus gemacht ich habe
nämlich Stollen gemacht mit Marzipan und
Karamell und dann auch noch mit einem
haselnusscunch also richtig lecker und
gar nicht so typisch wie man es kennt
aber ich sag's euch bleibt dran denn das
Rezept ist echt genial so es geht los
mit dem Hefeteig und dafür gebe ich
jetzt zu allererst Mehl allerdings nicht
alles in meine große Schüssel ein
bisschen zurückbehalten weil es kann ja
sein je nachdem wie groß das Ei ist dass
i nicht alles braucht übrigens Jasmin
eine sehr interessante Wahl der Schüssel
ist nich von meiner Schwiegermutter und
muss ich ihr noch
zurückgeben ja hast du mich jetzt gerade
dran erinnert so ich gebe jetzt hier
einmal noch Trockenhefe mit rein damit
ich das schon mal gut vermengt dann habe
ich hier noch an Gewürzen
muskatuskadamum und Zimt auch direkt mit
reineben und da kann ich dann schon
direkt Zucker warum habe ich das Ei so
random die ganze Zeit in der Hand ich
weiß es nicht ich gebe jetzt hier Zucker
mit rein das sind jetzt alle ich sag mal
trockenen Zutaten gewesen könnte einmal
ganz kurz und grob vermengen und da
kommt jetzt Milch am besten lauwarm
damit sich das auch gut verminkt und das
Ei mit hinein und anschließend sehr sehr
weiche Butter am besten am Vorabend
schon rausholen oder halt di Stunden
vorher dann vermingt sich das nämlich
alles wunderbar und was an Geschmack
auch nicht fehlen darf ist
Vanilleextrakt und Rumaroma das ist die
alkoholfreie var
zu rum und ich finde das Rumaroma jetzt
macht das einfach so winterlich und das
gehört für mich einfach mit
[Musik]
dazu so der Teig ist jetzt fertig das
daran dass der nicht mehr so doll klebt
der darf natürlich auch nicht zu trocken
sein also genauso ist der perfekt wenn
ihr anfasst und ihr könnt ganz normal
loslassen ist der wirklich optimal der
muss jetzt einmal ruhen ich Form den
hier ganz grob zu einer Kugel und dann
gebe ich das hier einmal in meine
luftdichte Schüssel ein bisschen
backtränkspray oder Öl ich gebe jetzt
ung noch mal Mehl dazu damit sich der
Mehl beim ruvorgang da nicht rein hinein
verarbeitet und der Teig dann dadurch
trockener wird und jetzt Ruh lassen 45
Minuten wenn ihr keine Zeit habt gehen
auch 30 aber an einem warmen Ort und
dann machen wir weiter so die Ruhezeit
ist um und wir kümmern uns jetzt um die
Toppings bzw das was da jetzt noch
reinkommt und zwar ich wollte es einfach
in einer richtig leckeren Kombination
machen ich nehme h mazipan das ist ganz
normale Marzipan Rohmasse immer wenn ich
mit Marzipan arbeite schreibt ihr mir ja
Kiki da ist doch Alkohol drin aber das
ist gar nicht so also ihr könnt ja auf
jeden Fall noch mal auf die Zutaten
schauen aber die die ich mir immer kaufe
die sind immer ohne Alkohol so und jetzt
schneide ich das einfach nur in so
kleine Vierecke und dann habe ich
außerdem noch karamellrops Bo so lecker
die Kombi karameldrops und geröstete
Haselnusskerne kommen da auch noch mit
[Musik]
rein
so den Teig jetzt einfach mit den Händen
ausbreiten da braucht ihr jetzt auch
kein ausrollstab für und ich habe das
jetzt ausgebereitet auf 25 x 20 cm und
jetzt kommen die ganzen Toppings oben
drauf mein lieblingspart ich bin aber
auch so ein Mensch ich übertreibe immer
richtig mit den Toppings schreib euch ja
auch wie immer die ganz genau
mengangaben unten in die Infobox wenn
ihr euch wundert wo denn die zu finden
sind ich find das so immer einfacher in
den Videos dann könnt euch das
screenshotten einkaufen gehen oder
gucken ob ihr die Sachen direkt zu Hause
habt und dann direkt einmal
nachmachen so ich gehe jetzt nicht ganz
so an den Rand weil ich will das ja
gleich verschließen s dass die Toppings
quasi im Stollen drin sind die Nüsse
geben noch Crunch ihr könntet jetzt auch
wahnüsse nehmen oder
Mandeln also all das was ihr möchtet
eigentlich was auch geben würde sind z.B
Schokodrops würde ich auch feiern aber
heute war ich so Team Karamell gebe ich
jetzt hier oben drauf dann drücke ich
das einfach nur so ein bisschen ein und
dann klappen wir erstmal die eine Seite
nach innen und dann die andere Seite und
dann ist es quasi fertig und kann noch
mal so ich würde sagen 20 bis maximal 30
Minuten unter einem Tuch gehen gelassen
werden damit es einfach noch mal ein
bisschen fluffiger wird dann kommt bei
180° Ober und Unterhitze in den
vorgeheizten
[Musik]
Backofen
so mein Stollen war jetzt für 40 Minuten
im Backofen also 40 bis maximum 44
Minuten länger braucht der nicht dadurch
dass jetzt auch nicht so xx riesengroß
ist halt eine gute Größe finde ich für
so ein normalen Vierpersonenhaushalt und
H gönt sich hier Baumkuchen mit Weiß
weißer Schokocreme auch nicht schlecht
Baumkuchen hat abgedreht und jetzt habe
ich essen es ist so richtig ich finde
das sind aber auch so richtige Winter
Weihnachtsrezepte so Stollen Baumkuchen
Stolle das ist eine Stolle genau das ist
ein Stollen und den hier bestreiche ich
jetzt hier noch mit zerlassener Butter
der ist auch noch lauwarm das ist auch
voll okay kann noch schön einzi das
kommt jetzt aber richtig also zu zu Hauf
oder wie sagt man ja jetzt sofort jetzt
gleich oder muss abkülen noch hier nein
nein jetzt kannst du das ja aber warte
zu Ende reichen vor allem ist es auch so
ein Stollen also der ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie konier h hallo da bitte ja
schon ordentlich machen hier nicht
konserviert mit Alkohol oder so und
deswegen hätte jetzt auch nicht so lange
wusstest du dass man Stollen wochenlang
essen kann eigentlich also man bereitet
sich den haltbar ja also ganz
traditionell das ist ja glaube ich jetzt
eher so
jetzt l mal kurz erzähen Fotos ist echt
interessant also die Leute bereiten sich
den Stollen eine Woche vom ersten Advent
zu damit eine Woche ziehen kann und
jeden Advent gönnen die sich dann ein
Stück also es ist ein Monat haltbar
eigentlich nicht für unseren Stollen
weil da ist jetzt das ist jetzt nicht
konserviert mit Alkohol und süß der
Gedanke aber wenn ich ein ster habe will
ich ster essen ja also der zieht auch
noch mal ein nach ein zwei Tagen
schmeckt der auch noch mal richtig
richtig intensiv aber den könnt ihr auch
sofort verspeisen kann ich machen hau
drauf jetzt zurück kannst du richtig
coole Shots machen jetzt von mir
[Musik]
so
da mus auf jed Fall Musik Drau ach
übrigens falls euch die Songs hier in
dem Video gefallen haben dann schaut
euch mal die topsifi weihnachtshit
Playlist an die habe ich euch nämlich in
der Infobox verlinkt schaut da gerne mal
rein dann kommt i so richtig in Stimmung
und ich finde jetzt die Zeit ist sowieso
Backen dabei Musik hören einfach
zelebrieren und ich liebe Backen im
Winter einfach noch viel viel mehr als
im Sommer anderes Feeling finde ich
immer so voll das andere Feeling so
Musik hört ne hast schon richtig toll
gemacht wuch meh machen ganz ehrlich und
mein Tipp wenn ihr das jetzt noch
richtig luftdicht verpackt dann bleibt
auch schön saftig aber wir schneiden den
gleich an dann machen wir gleich schon
den Tast
[Musik]
Test und habe ich euch jetzt zu viel
versprochen also ich finde ja gerade
jetzt hier auch beim Anschnitt sieht man
so richtig Karamel dann die
Haselnusskerne mazipan kann man auch
entdecken hier an vielen Stellen dadurch
dass wir es ja quasi in Stückchen
verteilt haben daher richtig gut
verteilt dass man in jedem Biss auch was
hat Bo ich gön mir jetzt einfach ich
habe da so Lust drauf gerade ja hier
merke ich auch schon ist ein dickes
Stückchen mazipar mit
dabei oh so lecker also ich find es
richtig lecker es schmeckt jetzt schon
saftig ich will nicht wissen wie es
morgen schmeckt also noch saftiger der
darf jetzt auch gerne noch mal wirklich
eine Nacht ziehen und einfach so richtig
man sieht es aber auch schon im
Anschnitt richtig lecker saftig einfach
ihr braucht keine spezielle Backform
dafür und könnt das aber auch so wie es
ist ja verschenken ich finde auch ein
Stollen zu verschenken ist eine richtig
schöne Idee oder halt zum zu
sonntagstafel mit einem leckeren
Cappuccino also Leute gönnt euch das
Rezept ich mache mir jetzt auf jeden
Fall noch ein Cappuccino dazu hau mich
auf die Couch und machen wir noch einen
schönen Abend und dann sage ich wir
sehen uns auch bei meinem nächsten
Rezept abonniert den Kanal kostenlos
Leute dann verpasst ihr die Rezepte auch
nicht mehr und dann sehen wir uns auch
macht's gut
[Musik]
ciao